One in seven people around the world
has some kind of disability.
Being born without my right hand
has defined who I am
over the past 30 years.
I was fortunate to grow [up]
in the sacred valley of the Incas
in Cusco, Peru,
surrounded by people who weren't surprised
to see me driving my bike
or probably playing basketball.
When I was seven, I remember being stunned
after I watched "Star Wars:
The Empire Strikes Back,"
when Luke's hand gets cut off,
the same one I didn't have.
But then, being twice as stunned
when the medical robots fitted him
with a prosthesis
that could move and feel.
From then on, no greater purpose
lived in my mind,
which was to have a prosthesis
like Luke Skywalker.
This dream led me to study
mechatronics engineering
and access the Biomechanics
and Applied Robotics Laboratory
in Pontifical Catholic University of Peru,
where, with a multidisciplinary team,
we developed a myoelectric prosthesis
for a long transradial amputation,
being me, the pilot user.
I was able to move
each finger individually.
And also we developed a way
in which we get to pass the sensation
from the fingertips into my forearm
using haptic feedback system.
Since this was a research project,
we had enough funding
to buy stuff from abroad.
So, for example, the motors
you get to see here,
were all brought [from] Switzerland.
This is one of the main reasons
why it will cost at least 40,000 dollars
to make this prosthesis.
But 40K is way too much,
considering that four out of five people
with upper limb amputation
live in developing countries.
Even the 25,000 dollars that cost
a robotic prosthesis imported from abroad
is way too much.
In Peru, that is equivalent
to work full time
on a minimum wage for almost seven years,
just to buy the prostheses.
Never mind pay
for your food or your house.
It is often that people get injured
while doing manual labor activities
like farming or metal manufacturing.
Getting back to work and having access
to money demands a functional hand.
It took me time to realize
what a huge privilege I had
to study a career that would help
fulfill my dreams.
But actually,
what was preventing me
from developing a solution
that was both affordable and functional.
The very first step
in order to reducing the cost
was to reduce the number of motors
because they were all imported
and therefore expensive.
So we get to arrange
occupational focus groups
with our amputee volunteers
in order to identify which gestures
they will use the most, and of those,
how many we could perform
using just a single motor.
The answer was three:
pinch,
cylindrical
and lateral.
This also helps us to reduce the number
of electromyography sensors, too,
from an arrangement of eight,
we passed just to one.
In this way, between makes in mechanical
and myoelectric prosthesis,
the prices will be dramatically low.
But material prices matter to.
And that's why we choose
to 3D print our prosthesis
using mainly plastic
from recycled bottles.
Like the prosthesis
I am wearing right now.
(Applause)
In order to develop our prosthesis,
the process will go like this.
First, we'll use our 3D scan
and our own parametrization software
in order to take the measures
of the amputated area
and the other hand of the user.
Then we'll recreate
the entire set of fingers,
the palm and the prosthesis socket
in our computational model
to finally 3D print each of those parts.
So far in LAT Bionics,
we have two types of prosthesis.
Maki, which is a mechanical activation
and Pisko, with electronic activation.
Pisko cost just 10 percent
of an imported robotic prosthesis
that will come from abroad.
This means that even more working-class
people can access our technology.
For me, this has been a path
where I was able to develop this
in my company LAT Bionics.
So, for example, take Franco,
[who] now is using
his transradial Maki prostheses
in order to get back to work
with his providers
on the jungle farm he has.
I am certain that we are able
to be on the side
with technology that is brought
from abroad to our region
being sold in a very expensive way.
We have the capacity to develop
our own technology,
having the necessities
of our people in mind.
So then people with disabilities
and limited resources
could live a life again.
For me, when people, our users,
get back to work on their places,
that look of compassion
changed to astonishment.
The same astonishment which I had
when I saw Luke Skywalker prosthesis.
So this began as a path for myself,
but it now belongs to my entire region.
Would you like to join us?
Thank you so much.
(Applause and cheers)